Uh, there is a completely mind blowing new
claim in a book, uh, which says that Robert
Mueller felt so strongly that Donald Trump
had actually committed criminal obstruction
that molar drafted indictment documents against
Donald Trump.
Now eventually, as we know, Mueller punted
on the issue of obstruction and Donald Trump,
he said in his report that although there
was substantial evidence of Donald Trump's
obstruction and I believe it was eight of
the possible 14 instances of obstruction for
political reasons, Robert Mueller decided
not to decide about indictment on obstruction
and sort of punted to Donald Trump's handpicked
attorney general William Barr, who obviously
no surprise said, yeah, we're not going to
indict Donald Trump, but is the claim made
in the book?
True?
I don't know.
I'm going to lay it all out for you and maybe
we can figure it out.
This is from Michael Wolf's latest book.
Now, you might remember Michael Wolfe wrote
his previous book, fire and fury, which had
all sorts of explosive claims about Donald
Trump and his administration and the people
around him, some of which have not been proven
to be true or at least have not been independently
corroborated outside of the book itself.
So we now get to Michael Wolfe's new book,
which is called siege Trump under fire.
And Wolf says is that Robert Mueller had actually
drawn up a three count obstruction of justice
indictment against President Donald Trump,
but that eventually he didn't file it and
the Guardian asked a spokesman for Robert
Mueller about this and Mueller Mueller spokesman
is flat out just saying didn't happen and
is quoted as saying, the documents that you've
described do not exist.
Now that language is relevant, at least possibly,
and I'll get back to that in a second.
Let's talk about wolf sources.
Wolf site's internal documents given to him
by sources close to the office of the special
counsel.
Okay.
Now what makes this claim not like other random
or particularly salacious claims that have
been made is that the documents exist.
The Guardian has looked at the documents that
Michael Wolf has.
There is a document which Michael Wolfe gave
to the Guardian which says under title 18
us code subsection 1505, that the president
the, this is a draft indictment.
The president is charged, uh, with corruptly
or by threats of force or threatening communication,
influencing, obstructing or impeding a pending
proceeding before a department or Agency of
the United States.
The second count in this draft indictment
that Michael Wolf looked at and showed it
to the Guardian is eight count under Section
1512 charging the president with tampering
with a witness, victim or informant.
The third count in this document that the
Guardian has looked at is under section 1513
charging Donald Trump with retaliating against
a witness, victim or informant.
Wolf says that the documents claim that Trump's
obstruction started on day seven of his administration.
And Wolf has endless additional documents
including a bunch of internal memos about
whether or not the president can be indicted
in the consensus of those documents.
Is that the answer is yes.
So the question is, are the documents real?
Is Molar spokesperson lying when he denies
the existence of the documents.
Are the documents fake?
If they're fake, who fake them?
Is it wolf?
Is that whoever gave them to wolf?
Is it somebody else?
There has to be some objective truth here.
Either this is real or it is not and it appears
to be binary except there is a sort of vocabulary
semantic possibility here.
If you look again at the statement from Robert
Mueller spokesperson, he said, quote, the
documents described do not exist.
These are lawyers.
Okay.
Documents described do not exist.
That is the present tense.
That is very different than saying the documents
never existed.
The claim from Michael Wolf is that the documents
existed, they were drafted and that they were
scrapped.
That is one possibility as to how everybody
is telling the truth.
There well, could have been a draft indictment
against Donald Trump.
It could have been scrapped and therefore
in a technical sense, Mueller spokesperson
is right.
The documents do not exist today.
May 29th, 20, 19.
Uh, there's another possibility that the documents
contained four counts against Donald Trump
and not three.
Technically.
That means that a document containing three
counts against Trump doesn't exist, but one
containing four or maybe two counts could
exist.
The Guardian looked at the documents and they
certainly aren't saying that the documents
are bogus.
And uh, we have the denial older spokesperson,
which could potentially be a very carefully
crafted non-denial.
I don't know, hopefully we'll know the truth
about these documents sometime soon.
But the end result of all of this is Mueller's
got to testify, right?
Molar silence is a growing problem.
It seems.
He may be sort of willing to testify before
the house judiciary committee if it's behind
closed doors.
But will he, won't he, I don't know the growing
questions around this really make it necessary
for him to sit down and most importantly,
remember what portion of the country has read
the Mueller report.
Is it 1%?
Is it 2% maybe 5% whatever that number is.
It's way too low.
And Robert Mueller testifying ideally publicly
would actually serve the purpose of informing
people about what's in the report.
Most of which remains unknown to the majority
of them are American population.
And that's why it's so important that Muller
testify.
That's why it's so important that the house
formally start a debate about impeachment
to get the content of the report out to more
than just the, I don't know, one, two or 5%
of the American public that has read it.
Let me know what you think about these claims
by Michael Wolf, the documents, the Guardian's
review of the documents.
I don't know what to think, but I do think
it's possible that the documents are real
and that the denial from Mueller spokesperson
as a very narrow meaning
that we should be interpreting.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
Uh, the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show.
I do want to hear from